it's time for our semi-regular newsdesk
advice column called
ask a desk
okay well today we're going to put it
into desk
experts
okay so we're going to set up questions
from people who have questions about
their exes oh okay okay yeah we can talk
about that right
are we sure we should do this
sounds dangerous but no we'll see what
happens you know i'm not
i think it's going to be great so let's
start with sherry hi sherry hi how are
you good thank you for having me what is
your
ex issue
my ex has some of his stuff still in my
place and it's uh he hasn't asked for it
yet and it's taking up some room in my
house so i'm just wondering can i sell
it can i throw it out
is it some pretty good stuff
um some
yeah we'll keep that stuff
what about the rest of it bonfire
i'm thinking the same thing
how are you in terms of
are you on good terms no okay understood
okay
maybe just put it in a box and text hey
it's on the front porch come grab it
that'd be the nicest thing to do but if
you're not on great terms i think the
bonfire is a good idea
a good bonfire you're all invited yeah
that sounds fun can i ask what in your
heart of hearts you really want to do
with it
burn it yeah
[Applause]
yeah and maybe take a video
and dance around that bonfire
absolutely
we're here for that
all right next up we've got an x issue
coming to us from kenya who's on zoom hi
kenya
talk to us everyone
hi
oh
well you're good
we are so excited to help you what do
you need our help with
okay so i have an ex and we broke up
because he cheated now we both moved on
it's been several years
but he recently reached out wanting to
reconnect
and i'm like
uh i don't know about that because you
know you know now my question is is that
can men change and like do you think i
should give him a second chance or not
oh i love this question no
really no no
men don't change
[Laughter]
[Applause]
well
you want to be with somebody that when
they look at you
you're the only person that they could
imagine being with right
yeah absolutely
so
no second chances
yeah get on tinder
[Laughter]
i kind of think yeah
so here's the deal i do think people can
change and grow but i also think you
know it's like leftovers in the fridge
you gotta
throw it out if the expiration date is
passed
it's no good because i don't think
you'll you'll ever be able to approach
that person with the same pure love like
you did before so
[Music]
that is
serious baggage
and do you still have feelings for him
that's important
because i don't think i still have
villains for him i think i'm just open
because i'm single um but i think i know
the answer is like no but i'm just kind
of like trying to give somebody a second
chance if it's possible you know yeah
yeah maybe you just hit it one more time
and then quit it and be like
i meant to do this six years ago
i have also just more questions like
did this happen once or repeatedly
do you have pictures then it's a no
then it's a no and i'm very serious
about this that's not an accident oh
yeah that's far from it buh-bye repeated
buh-bye
and what tom said i mean god that should
not be the standard what's wrong with us
okay ross um we have one word from
twitter yeah okay yeah we have one more
our last ex question comes to us from
nancy on twitter and her ex this is
interesting her ex invited her to his
wedding they're friendly yeah wow
they're friendly and she plans to go but
nancy wants to know one thing what kind
of gift do you give your ex and their
new wife for their wedding wow
a candle i don't know right
here's the thing i nancy you have to
walk that line of the gift can't be too
personal because his new wife's going to
be like thanks nancy
i see you nancy i see you so i allowed
you to come to the wedding and now you
cross that line yeah i we paid for your
chicken cordon bleu now you're coming
after my man i don't think so so you
just have to find a sweet spot
how do you feel about this tom i mean it
is interesting that she's invited i
would assume that they both invited her
so that means that the wife is
comfortable the future wife is
comfortable with her coming so
maybe you could take that as a hint and
a good gift could be a threesome
[Applause]
that is the gift that just keeps on
giving
you never know
could be fun
can i answer can i ask you guys a
question yeah would you ever go to an
ex's wedding
i've never been invited to an ex's
wedding
[Applause]
which makes sense to me i i honestly i
think it makes sense to probably not go
to
a nexus wedding i think so too i think
so yeah but you know you could also be
kind of healthy you know i think it's
weird yeah i do too
i'm with tom on this one 100 like
just keep it clean ross you have a
wedding coming up
how dare you
in
um
we gotta go to break thanks tom green
for being here
[Music]